guys i want to get my hands on those so
i'm salivating i apologize right i know
what's your favorite pie i was going to
ask that this is why we know each
other's whole life i know peach okay you
pumpkin yeah
you guys you guys are pumpkins yeah
that's good stuff yeah i could do
pumpkin all right the crust just eat the
top part oh yeah let's do the four
o'clock what about you
do you like pumpkin also
yeah pumpkin yeah it's that time of the
year too right and this looks like one
of those like fall sunsets right because
sunset's now 429. enjoy that with some
pumpkin pie yes right a nice coffee
can we can we get some pumpkin pie in
here possible
all right sweet don't forget the whipped
cream all right live look outside right
now great shot from a tower cam yeah a
lot of clouds out there but more clouds
are on the way we checked up on air
quality too everything is good with
exception to the small particulate
matter that's now back up to the
moderate range not a big problem again
air quality is still good for ozone and
carbon too currently outside 66 sky
canyon centenny hills same for you 67
aliante 71 sunrise matter so there are
some spots that have reached the 70
degree mark and that's still that's okay
still very pleasant 70 for whitney ranch
and green valley 71 for sunrise manor
that doesn't surprise me because you
guys are lower in elevation remember the
valley goes down in elevation 65 for
henderson
68 mountains edge and also rhodes ranch
regional chapter 61 for indian spring 62
for searchlight 73 currently for la flip
all right here's our satellite and radar
you'll notice the clouds coming in off
from the southwest this is all ahead of
what we called yesterday hopefully you
joined us yesterday after the raiders
game we have this cut off flow all by
itself here that will be moving south of
us increasing the cloud cover but what
are our shower chances the prospects of
those showers haven't been too high and
looks like it's going to stay that way
unfortunately as we get to tomorrow
and also into wednesday look at shower
chances mainly into arizona not big
chances happening here and then those
clouds erode tomorrow later on in the
day so we'll start off with clouds in
the morning and then we'll see some
sunshine in the afternoon with the
shower chances again confined to arizona
one thing we're confident about though
we are going to get some wind to return
that's going to be specifically
wednesday breezy winds up to 30 35
gustier down the colorado valley and the
lake and then we'll have some leftover
north winds on thursday at least for the
first half of the day we think all right
after that those winds decrease for
black friday and beyond in your weekend
51 degrees overnight thicker clouds look
for light winds overnight so we'll have
the cloud cover
wind should stay light to calm and we're
not expecting any rainfall unfortunately
74 tomorrow we'll see clouds in the
morning and then as the day progresses
after midday we'll start to see more
sunshine again wednesday light for
tomorrow will increase tomorrow night
though and they'll be breezy like we
said on wednesday neighborhood by
neighborhood temperatures your highs
tomorrow 65 in summerlin 69 for north
las vegas 72 green valley 68 for
mountain zed so we'll still be nice and
mild as we head through the day tomorrow
even with the cloud cover 67 for prompt
68 for boulder city 78 for lafayette
here's your eight day forecast
there's the
still peaking i'm trying to figure out
what's up with him all right
temperatures will be dropping the low 60
cold start for thursday morning i'll
have more on that and your travel
forecast coming up kirsten over today
teddy that
poor guy's had a little too much eggnog
and